the next topic is Google Cloud billing
billing is established at the project
level
this means that when you define a Google
Cloud project you link a billing account
to it
this billing account is where you'll
configure all your billing information
including your payment option
a billing account can be linked to zero
or more projects but projects that
aren't linked to a billing account can
only use free Google cloud services
billing accounts are charged
automatically and invoiced every month
or at every threshold limit
billing sub-accounts can be used to
separate billing by project
some Google Cloud customers who resell
Google cloud services use sub-accounts
for each of their own clients
you're probably thinking how can I make
sure I don't accidentally run up a big
Google Cloud bill
we provide a few tools to help
you can Define budgets at the billing
account level or at the project level
a budget can be a fixed limit or it can
be tied to another metric for example a
percentage of the previous month spend
to be notified when costs approach your
budget limit you can create an alert
for example with a budget limit of
twenty thousand dollars and an alert set
at ninety percent you'll receive
notification alert when your expenses
reach eighteen thousand dollars
alerts are generally set at 50 90 and
100 but can also be customized
reports is a visual tool in the cloud
console that lets you monitor
expenditure based on a project or
services
finally Google Cloud also implements
quotas which are designed to prevent the
overconsumption of resources because of
an error or a malicious attack
protecting both account owners and the
Google Cloud Community as a whole
there are two types of quotas rate
quotas and allocation quotas
both are applied at the project level
rate quotas reset after a specific time
for example by default the gke service
implements a quota of 1000 calls to its
API from each Google Cloud project every
100 seconds
after that 100 seconds the limit is
reset
allocation quotas govern the number of
resources you can have in your projects
for example by default each Google Cloud
project has a quota allowing it no more
than five virtual private Cloud Networks
although projects will start with the
same quotas you can change some of them
by requesting an increase from Google
Cloud support
if you're interested in estimating cloud
computing costs on Google Cloud you can
try out the Google Cloud pricing
calculator at cloud.google.com forward
slash products forward slash calculator